I'm curious so you're a doctor did you
like what's your experience with have
you ever like worked with doctors that
have done abortions or what's your oh
wow yeah I actually have a friend who
ran B pass the largest devotion provider
in the country she was the CEO but she's
a very sincere honest woman who thinks
she's doing the right thing for women
and so you know
um yeah we have a good friendship and I
have plenty of colleagues who do
abortions I obviously disagree with them
you know in the Hippocratic Oath it's it
literally explicitly says I will not do
abortions it's been pretty pretty
integral to the medical profession for
centuries and centuries
um I did not know that yeah it's um most
people don't know actually someone said
did you not take an oath why are you
pro-life and the oath literally says you
can't do abortions
um it's pretty wild
um yeah for me you know this is this is
an issue that is both ethical but it's
also medical like when you look at the
outcomes women who have abortions for an
unwanted pregnancy this is women who
have an unwanted pregnancy if you have
an abortion you have a 30 increased risk
of anxiety a 70 increased risk of
suicide a 130 increased risk of alcohol
abuse and a 300 increased risk of drug
abuse and that's if you don't have one
if you if you haven't if you have one
yeah yeah compared to the same women
with the same previous psychiatric
issues the same socioeconomic stuff the
same unwanted pregnancy correlation
doesn't equal causation there could be a
number of variables for those reasons
but that's why they take into account
all of those things so they adjust for
socioeconomic status for previous
psychiatric history for domestic
violence for all sorts of things and
they find even when you keep those
constant the women who have abortions
have much worse mental health well and I
and I think it's just common sense to be
honest this is why sometimes I'm like
you don't even need to study to tell you
that like I know women that have had
abortions they're never happy after the
women that are keeping them are more
likely to be in happy relation in the
first place if they have the support
they're going to have better but this is
like you it's always a cope it's always
there's somehow yeah
I'm coping
women have never heard that argument
when when we're talking about
um
when we're talking about
um the pig up so you will never hear a
woman say well there are so many other
factors that could contribute to it but
it's funny how you say that that was
never my argument either
we were talking about you well he was
pointing at me
though but I think it's funny because
it's so it's so funny it's just
something I notice with girls it's
always like they take the argument and
it's like they always use me but it's
not about you well here I was the one
yeah
I'm not talking about you I'm talking
about in general
um so you said you're I'm curious can
you tell me what happens during an
abortion
yeah it really depends on the kind of
abortion so there's two main kinds
there's medical which means using pills
or there's surgical so in a medical
abortion you take two pills the first
pill will you know deprive the baby of
oxygen and nutrients so that it
basically suffocates and then the second
poem isoprostol will eject the baby and
cause you know labor cause a miscarriage
at a very late stage because the baby
could be born alive like if you do this
at 22 weeks the baby might come out of
the womb alive you have to perform a
procedure called feticide which you can
guess what that means it's the killing
of a fetus and that's one of the reasons
for thinking this is a living thing
right they wouldn't call it feet aside
if it wasn't alive wait so they'll
they'll kill it after it comes out no no
so what they do is before they do the
abortion they will put a needle through
the mummy mother's tummy and they will
stick it into the baby's heart or
sometimes into the head and they will
pump in potassium chloride and that will
kill the baby now this has been banned
potassium chloride in capital punishment
so if you look at human rights groups
they say you cannot use this chemical in
capital punishment because it's inhumane
to kill rapists and murderers this way
but this is exactly the same chemical
they use to perform feticide in late
term abortions now those are a small
number but you know they still occur
there's still hundreds of them each year
in this country
surgical abortions are quite different
at an early stage you use a vacuum so
that basically vacuums the baby and
destroys the baby through the force of
the vacuum after about 12 13 14 weeks
the baby is too kind of big and tough to
be vacuumed and so you have to dismember
it so you basically just pull the limbs
off the baby bit by bit it's horrible to
think about horrible to say I don't like
saying it but it's just the reality it's
a dismemberment basically
um if the baby's head is too big to
remove from the womb they will have to
crush the head should bring it out so
it's it's pretty horrendous and if you
read academic papers where abortion
providers give their thoughts on it many
of them say actually this is terrible
many abortion providers say I'm only
going to do it up to 12 weeks because
after that it's just too horrible
um so it's it's something that you know
most abortions are in the first
trimester I'm not pretending that most
abortions of these horrible gruesome
late term things but just as an example
there are three thousand abortions in
this country after 20 weeks each year so
after 20 weeks five months when the
baby's pretty much viable
three thousand abortions take place by
those sorts of methods and so it's still
something that you know if three
thousand children were being killed by
that method in any other circumstance
we'd say that's way too many that's
three thousand too many
um yeah sorry that was very deep so what
happened in the first one you said
they're deprived of nutrients can I
challenge you on that because I've
looked up both of these drugs so you
spoke about my super personal but me for
Prestone is the the first one that's
more common it's an anti-proteistogen
yes and it causes the cervix and uterine
vessels to dilate and then it causes a
contraction I don't see it anywhere
where it's like
doing what you're saying yeah so it has
a number of mechanisms so
um there's you know three or four or
five different ways that it acts but the
main thing that it does if you search
online it will say it breaks down the
uterine lining so it basically breaks
down the connection between the mother
and the baby and of course that
connection is what's providing the
oxygen and so on sometimes the baby does
survive it
um usually the baby is killed by the the
deprivation of oxygen if it does survive
then it would be the contractions of the
uterus that will you know squash it and
usually end its life yes so essentially
the drugs that would I mean some of
these drugs are still used for induction
of Labor and such and well one of them
is also used for stomach ulcers or
something
so I I I find it I I don't know I feel
like the way that you said it especially
for the first drug it it felt more
emotional especially since because
they're having these uh abortions so
early on
when you're saying depriving the baby of
oxygen is it breathing because
I think it's breathing is it no so it
gets oxygen through the umbilical cord
but no matter how you're getting oxygen
if you're deprived of it you will still
have the same physics yes but I think
using words like breathing invokes an
emotional response in all of us and
we're thinking oh it's this little thing
I didn't say everything you said
breathing I think you did you said the
problem
yeah you didn't
I I said it deprives of oxygen I didn't
say it was breathing you know the the
oxygen is coming through the umbilical
cord
um and that is just how it works now I'm
not saying the baby is conscious from
the moment of conception I don't believe
that I'm not trying to pretend that from
the moment of conception the baby will
feel things and will always feel
something during an abortion but
certainly by the end of the first
trimester I think is extremely likely
and we don't know exactly when
Consciousness begins but it probably
does begin within the first trimester
and at that point if you deprive the
baby of oxygen it doesn't matter whether
you're you know covering its head or
just cutting the umbilical cord or
whatever
when your body is deprived of oxygen if
you are conscious then you know that
will
that will affect you and that is what
causes the the demise of the yes but I I
guess with the Consciousness argument it
doesn't bother me because babies don't
even get self-awareness to 15 odd months
and I don't advocate for throwing babies
into dumpsters so the Consciousness that
a thing this small has is relatively
Irrelevant in my opinion obviously not
to everyone else here so why didn't you
think it has self-awareness till 15
months because it doesn't pass the
mirror test until around then you can't
acknowledge that it exists in it but
that doesn't mean I think babies should
be thrown in dumpsters just because it
doesn't have self-awareness capabilities
yet it hasn't even reached stage one
doesn't mean that I don't think it is an
entity that is existing that should be
protected and has protections sure but I
think most neurologists and
psychologists would say the mirror test
is not a good test of self-awareness
well it doesn't pass any self-awareness
tests until around that age but again
but I don't think it's important because
I don't advocate for destruction of
babies when they're born so whether the
whether there is any like valuable
Consciousness there doesn't really
matter too much to me so you think if it
feels excruciating pain as like a
newborn baby that doesn't matter no I
don't think pain matters now
I sound like a sociopath now but it's a
pain is a very little of consequence to
me it's a when you're dead you won't
feel it I mean they used to think that
newborn babies don't feel pain so they
used to do surgery on newborn babies
because they said these newborn babies
can't feel pain they're not sufficiently
conscious and they're not sufficiently
self-aware and so they would just do
surgery on newborn babies without any
painkillers without any anesthesia but
they changed that a few decades ago
because there was a pretty unanimous
consensus within medical science that
newborn babies can feel pain even if
they can't pass the mirror test
yes but if well regardless of when they
feel pain
if they are not of any kind of valuable
Consciousness to me which I don't think
they gain until much older
it doesn't matter because it
it's just trying to put an emotional
response on a blob
it it is not an entity that is developed
enough for anything to be of any
importance the pain receptors
are just irrelevant to me it doesn't
know of its existence it doesn't know of
its pain so why does the pain matter if
it doesn't know of it as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible